here we go let's roll
you have the Petroff again we're gonna
have the Cochran's gambit no fantasy
land or now let's try to exchange
Carroll exchange caro-kann Bishop d3 and
I might want to say no do you do not
develop that bishop
that's what h3 is looking to do so what
gets done with this Bishop Knight c6
if I play Knight f3 there's night b4 if
I check the bishop blocks and this is
something black is welcome to do keep in
mind from this structure black is
perfectly happy with exchanging light
squared bishop here we go to gather my
thoughts on that one
ah so wait that said what do you think
this bishops ready to do Bishop b5 if I
play c3 if right Castle a Bishop b5 is
played now there's a couple of ways I
could defend against that Bishop move
one Queen e2 and to a4
I think this is a spot my queen would
like to go to anyhow
it's less committal
I like it let's go now if my opponent
says you know what I really want to get
my Bishop to b5 I'm gonna say you know
what I really don't want it to get there
with a 4 it's much more convenient for
me to be preventing this bishop move
that my opponent is you know it's not an
inconvenience for me to have to be
dealing with that eventually the Knights
to play here and I don't have to worry
about that me love it ever so night here
is one thing I could do and Castle c3
Gasol seems like it's good I can't move
my bishop just yet
let's Castle and I here c3 I don't want
to deal with night before
I might have to be concerned if I
playing this a4 move knight c6 a5 b 3
stuff hopefully I could get my Bishop
out and then my knight to d2 a knight on
D 2 would counteract a knight on a 5
let's go here this was being placed
under fire a d4 point Knights that are
on the same diagonal with exactly two
squares separating them are often
fighting for the same squares picture it
Knight a5 what is it looking to do from
there the two word test now what now
what from a5 b3 or c4 maybe if I have my
knight on D 2 its guarding b3 in c4
ok I think I want to get a knight right
here my dark square bishop is just gonna
end up getting kicked around bishop here
there might even be Knight h 5 to f4
stuff let's get my rook here and I'm
actually considering really Lopes type
of stuff right now and by that I mean
Knight d2 F 1 maybe here even though
could compromise my king side structure
or maybe here to e3 with the g4 and then
e5 ID in mind I'm gonna come here while
I have the opportunity to do just that
and I think I go still on my little
journey and there's a couple different
ways I could get to g4 actually I don't
know if I want to play here because then
there's maybe the possibility for a 5 so
maybe H to g4 I'd have double G puns but
that can actually be quite good I could
use that as a spearhead for an attack I
already have two bishops pointing at the
king
this one right here not even needing to
be developed and it's already an
aggressive piece keep that in mind
sometimes your pieces don't need to
develop and they could already be in a
good spot granted this rook isn't able
to help out until this guy moves but in
any event Knight h2 to g4 is a
possibility and I think I like it enough
to just
- just do it right
95 is another one there is no night
takes because of pond takes with the
fork so if I do position my knight and
the bishop has to take pawn recaptures
in the knight is running out of squares
ooh that is actually something I'm
liking better than the knight h2 to g4
idea if I prevent this pond for moving
the bishop clearly will not be coming
out in this direction well even actually
even if it did it's it's still it's
really struggling this bishop if the
knight isn't captured now I could be
supporting it with f4 mmm
this could be big trouble soon I might
want to run with g4 despite how a
weakening it is I might have ideas of
Knight g3 to h5 a pivot point targeting
these I have a one two three four pieces
that could maybe cause the king some
trouble a fifth one is a couple moves
off and a sixth one is just a couple of
moves off so really it's just this ruck
so now I think I run with actually
Bishop here get my Bishop out or no pawn
here yeah I'm gonna do that well you
know what's gonna happen B this is this
movie's gonna be played and I'm not
gonna stop at this time with a four
because I don't like the thought of a
knight coming to b3 so forget about that
and sure enough that's what we're having
here or maybe I should actually could I
actually deal with the night sitting
right here a four-night b3 would be one
I dropped that a pun mmm I like that
let's not do it okay what do we do then
I think I want to get this pawn involved
let me see clock situation where are we
at think here I don't need my Jeep on I
was considering first this move and then
and then Knight g3 but I think this is
most direct less weakening I could have
also considered taking the bishop oh why
did I consider that why did I consider
that ah that would have been good right
let's break this open oh man
I'm lucky I'm not dropping a piece right
now I thought I could recapture with my
night I couldn't because this would be
hanging why didn't I just take that
bishop even though it was a dummy it
would allow for my LightSquared bishop
to eventually do some damage to the king
less than a minute if I can sort this
out then I can't go too far because of
forks now we're gonna have a queen trade
I guess we're gonna have a queen trade
aren't we
okay Queen trade it is and I think I
want to come here if Bishop takes I
think I'll take with the pun or
something this is uh this is a problem
for me okay oh okay fortunately I
actually have stuff working out bishop
check bishop block oh this is a problem
I'm on two nights at that point that was
a miscalculation but this is still not
so easy to be winning I gotta watch this
pawn I think pawn takes I can't know I
could take with the night I'm gonna take
now that the file isn't opened not they
have file the rook isn't on there I'm
gonna run home if there's a check it's
double up also rush up here let's get
out of that get that rook out of there
guard these pawns first and foremost I
don't want to drop this let's get here
18 seconds they're flying I don't have
any time there's Forks and stuff right
here
clock situation oh they're flying
they're flying here pre means
what is the count here Oh stuff is
falling quickly pigs where the pigs
looking for the pigs more pigs more fuel
on this point that pond is crashing
don't allow for stalemate six seconds
oh they resigned oh I was gonna get nuts
right there at the end I guess there was
maybe some possibility for a stalemate
right at the end but what a tight game
my opponent kicked it into a higher gear
right there and caught me off guard I
was doing too much talking too late
right there so be aware of this idea
first and foremost the exchange
variation of the caro-kann this ID in
other words being to not allow the
bishop to come out to either f5 or g4
this age three move stops up the two
squares the bishop can be going to now
the Queen b6 move I think there's some
improvement on it I wonder about night
c6 and after c3 because again otherwise
I don't want to deal with the night to
b4 so after 96 and c3 I think you could
be getting in this e5 move but it's not
without having to then deal with an
isolated Queen pond so be aware of that
be aware of that possibility the knight
c6 and then you could get any five you
will have to deal with that type of
structure I think I stand better in this
position and I didn't make the best
choices these are good spots for the the
bishop and the knight classic squares
for the knight are hard to argue with I
get my knight in that f4 and right here
I could do better as soon as my opponent
is threatening to actually get their
Bishop here I think I should be taking
this and then getting my knight to g3
and maybe even well actually h2 and g4 I
think would be even better take this and
then
age too actually I think is best because
I can maybe go to g4 or f3 to e5 did you
follow that instead of the move I played
Knight g3 right now take this bishop
even though it's the bad bishop and it's
not doing anything it's getting ready to
another way to view it is that it's
getting ready to get rid of a very
valuable a very key ingredient in an
eventual King side attack towards black
here so chop the knight has to retreat
to recapture of course and then Knight
h2 to one of these two squares and
things are going to be really good I
believe so that's an improvement
and now Queens coming off this is double
pawns but so what it's a they're not
accessible pawns aren't necessarily a
target unless you can do what unless you
can exploit them right here Bishop takes
is a mistake so I think Knight takes
pawn takes with the fork but there is a
way out of it
Bishop check I could block and then the
night could be reacting or there could
be Bishop check and I'll have to
recapture with my rook otherwise there's
maybe takes pawn check or something but
that's there gonna be the way to save a
piece right here not not throw in Bishop
takes Knight but rather Knight takes
tonight or even retreat and then target
this guy or something but we're about in
time pressure at that point where we
okay good game